[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bourgeois le globe
bonjour le monde entier comment il est
bienvenu dans n'ai pas senti le berge où
ça nous l'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous les dans le port du pas
j'ai dû rouler au port et nous fait
découvrir le chocolat donc émission peut
être un petit peu spécial un d'avoir
l'aura des petits plants qui changent
comme ça mais tout ça c'est pour votre
bien
c'est pour découvrir le chocolat à
léguevin vie devient vite très vite
parce que novak hull après bonjour
patrick comment il est bonjour les là où
même souffle m s et d'accueil à nous
bienvenue à la chocolaterie du port dans
la zac 2000 sûr que la tri du port aux
marmailles donc la cause nationale à là
je vous accueillir dans l'atelier
chocolat tri vous allez voir comment on
fabrique de chocolat c'est en fait tu
vas avec très peu de phrases c'est fou
comme google on va de la chocolaterie et
à l'eau allons allons
[Musique]
bon va falloir s'équiper comme on est
dans la vie en entreprise
agroalimentaire pour respect de
l'hygiène et de la qualité il faut des
protections toujours des protections
c'est un fait non on est dans les loges
le concert a bien commencé dauphin du
mahdi c'est ça il va on va entrer dans
la transaction
où est ce qu'on va partir tu dis lente
et de production parce que tu as une
attaque directe de la télé production
alors que moi on va voir le chocolat oh
là là les enfants allez on y va aller
[Musique]
alors dit moi justement ici ça va être
notre zone on prépare les ingrédients
qui vont venir dans les tablettes les
ingrédients y avait pas ce qu on a
tellement on a le chocolat chocolat dont
cacao c'est ça mais mais n'est pas afin
que vous autres c'est ça c'est ça
ici on a on fait des tablettes avec
plusieurs types de parfum et tablettes
simple avec eux
les parfums comme la vanille on a aussi
des tablettes avec du fourrage avec de
la pâte de fruits par exemple là
aujourd'hui on a de la pâte de fruit
qu'on ne peut pas d'accord écoutez la
voix le coup je n'attendrai pas à quoi
là en ce moment on peut parler aux
fourrages pour la tablette
bon vous aviez alors à sa marmaille
mais j'ose il ya une odeur mais on
dirait mais pareil au mellick sûr que
matt on donne un show dont le chocolat
alors là on a dû une préparation du
fourrage boy a mis d'accord préparé un
fourrage goyaviers et ici on a déjà un
forage qui est pris mejia du chocolat là
dedans non il ya du chocolat on
mais c'est également comme ça ah oui un
mail en suivant
oui ça c'est terrible les enfants les
jolies parce qu'en fait on voit le
chocolat et aux voix le goyavier et les
faits qu'ils font et ouais on a
l'impression ou game est une bougie dans
ce combat mais je on a l'impression que
c'est ça alors on voulait tuer
oui c'est pas moi qui demande débouté un
attention hein voilà allons
[Musique]
alors
une tuerie
c'est bon c'est bon donc goyavier sans
poisson l'occase 100% local d'accord au
niveau du chocolat est-ce que du
chocolat main je te parle pas des
fourrages ni départ afin de mieux est ce
que tu es un du local aussi pour le coup
j'ai pas dans le cacao dans les sucres
dans non c'est du chocolat qui vient de
la métropole d'apport et donc la
particularité c'est justement par
rapport à tout ce qui est fourrage
oui sauf has to v10 est d'accord voilà
on va le présenter des on va le
présenter des défauts du cacao c'est moi
je connais des producteurs de cacao
dis moi tu peux me donner un petit peu
comment l'on fait tout ça les
ingrédients pour les ingrédients nobles
et nagoya vie mais à part ça elle a subi
des hausses à la sarre en place un jour
là non non je n'en sais rien qu'à nous
fait ça écoute vous donne la recette me
donner mon cul et chocolat on va pleurer
braves gens vous allez rire apparaître
chocolat goyavier de cases c'est pas
grave faut acheter faudra acheter vous
c'est quoi la prochaine étape
alors la prochaine étape c'est intégré
naufrage on y va
[Musique]
écoutez monsieur alors ce monsieur il
est le responsable adjoint de la
chocolaterie d'accord et
e
l'opérateur qui va faire les pas mettre
d'accord donc l'ami croire qu'on nous a
causé que ce monsieur la balle mes coups
de monsieur a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors donc ici on a un fort ans en
préparation mais dans la machine
on a convié parents fait il va falloir
terminer d'abord d'accord avant de
verser ce deuxième parfum donc le 2
février ville polynésie
qui repousse hilda dentaire mélange de
gomme ça doit être bon quand même
paris
voilà c'est des mots différents qu'on va
laisser remplir
on
voilà la gaule est sûr qu'on rachète
tablettes au polar pur
le d'emplois
je
alors c'est ici que commence le fameuse
coquille voilà donc voilà donc je
n'allais moule que les larmes là le
chocolat qui sont d'ordre la dose
précise racing qui ça va là bas en scéne
un renversement remplacement qui enlève
le chocolat en trop tu vas laisser la
coquille à l'intérieur voilà refroidir
ensuite voilà ce chocolat clé pas là en
fait c'est les fourrages qui va venir
pouvoir là qui va venir donc la coquille
ce sera ça une force qui fabrique et non
en semaines mais voilà la défense et
refroidit aussi tous d'accord bon alors
on a fait les comptes et ouais mais pour
moi rien les cookies il faut cependant
mmc des drops
d'accord ça peut être dit les sapeurs du
blanc sa patience a pourtant fait le
show et une fois que ces fondus au mal
et tempérées que c'est à dire des
centres de santé run à une température
de 30 degrés pour pouvoir donner dans
les moules l'afoc association baptisée
la compta 30 du bus n'a pas jane fonda
pouvoir musée
[Musique]
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire maintenant
maintenant aller à ma sortie pour voir
le débat et des tablettes
alors qu'une femme on a mis le faudra
tous fermés on va du peintre la fin de
la chaîne
bon ben voilà ici on arrive on va dire
enfin de fabrication tous ses tablettes
de chocolat la pousse à la plata miam
miam
dans leur vie de manger aux dépens de
l'as cookies jusqu'à l'emballage final
on a trois heures du temps donc ça veut
dire cela c'est du chocolat de la fille
ce matin même depuis ce matin ça veut
dire que chocolat fait le matin on m'a
les deux protagonistes à la journée
une fois qu'on a fait le procès de
championnat sion les produits sont là on
va en emballée et prête à livrer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles
alors dis-moi où sa nou lé là alors
comme on a fini à de voir la production
de tablettes
ici on va faire l'assemblage des boîtes
de noël dis moi il ya combien de
variétés de chocolats là et qu'on mène
parfum alors un type de de bonbons on a
tous variétés non à relever confondues
est ce que c'est la même chaîne de
préparation là on a vu que la laddh les
machines labazée et faisait des
tablettes qui sépare et c est ce que
c'est les mêmes machines qui s'occupe de
ces de ses chocolats alors c'est
exactement la même machine
en fait ce qui change c'est du moule
voilà ces liens à différents types de
moules pour les tablettes pour le bon
bout et du coup c'est vraiment la même
machine qui d'accord donc en tablette de
chocolat j'étais arrivé à combien par
jour alors actuellement on est environ 1
600 kg jour qui ont collaboré simule
tablette par jour par jour màj d'eau
aujourd'hui on est là sur les mots comme
ça on est à trois cents 300 350 kg jour
tout ou pas afin confondues toutes
formes confondues tous d'accord voilà à
peu près mais une petite question est
combien de temps que la chocolaterie
tunisie alors la chocolaterie existe
depuis 1994
mais le nouveau bâtiment est là depuis
2015 d'accord voilà donc tout le monde
et travaille t elle ayem chocolat tout
le monde
lim chocolat et au chocolat ou en
chocolat des sixièmes jeux cramé images
hautement donc pour résumer des fruits
et des produits locaux
plusieurs variétés de chocolats tout à
fait et de et de gommage et des dom de
fruits ou ne veut pas de ce type de pâte
de fruit voilà on n'a pas vu on a les
tablettes ce qu'on appelle nous a pas de
dégustation
la visite à l'heure on peut mettre du
caramel du seul de saint-benoît là et on
a aussi les bonbons
dark aujourd'hui est ce que toi tu
aurait quelque chose à rajouter
alors alors sur la société en elle même
c'est une socatri où les gens sont
passionnés vraiment les gens qui
travaillent dans cette chocolaterie 10e
femme chocolat est vraiment passionné
aujourd'hui on a du matériel qui à la
pointe de la technologie
on a c'est la seule dinky à la réunion
aujourd'hui et les opérateurs sont prêts
personnels est d'accord mais il dit au
revoir et bon bien qu'on entendra
bientôt on va faire des items à ça parce
que mamie connaissez pas mais parce que
les délits ces créatures est pareil ah
ben ça se fait un plaisir de découvrir
une la réunion qui fabrique qui produit
avec des produits locaux
c'est plus intéressant c'est bien pour
un million mais bien sûr que c'est pour
leur réunion c'est bien si surtout aussi
pour les autres tous ces producteurs de
fruits que voilà au moins un qui connaît
un qualité pays et que pour oman jeune
thibault ya vu un d'orlov des palmistes
je pense à voilà quoi c'est ça c'est
tout c'est tout un émoi toute façon rien
qu'avec l'odeur vous malgré mon envie à
mon vivant ou même en village et patrice
midi mais ça fait mal tout chocolat ne
retrouve même si comme ça comme ça comme
ça comme ça ils sont petits quand tu
vois merci beaucoup merci
et puis médias ou simplement la
prochaine fois d'accord et 10 mois pour
s'en tire donc cette droite gauche
gauche droite gauche d'escalier des sens
et c'est fini voilà c'est vrai tu as
droit rpa gauche droite c'est bien je
devrais je me retiens droite gauche non
droite
non non non
eh oui toutes les bonnes choses ont une
fin
c'est terminé on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge mais aujourd'hui mais ne vous
en faites pas enfin je vais revenir
promis juré me revient alors aux médias
tout simplement aurevoir à la prochaine
fois et oublie pas là c'est un moment
très important
on n'est pas du tout sorti de l'auberge
- médias note et les très simple mais si
pas pourquoi parce que quand on rentre
dans l'auberge un moment donné natalie
portman est en fait après l'un des
seigneurs et l'appui de la wii dans
notre chocolat mais chocolat marmaille
chocolats fourrés goyavier pour un anna
banti chocolat - là non non non non et
non
[Musique]